we go any further I wanna thank y'all  from the bottom of my heart for being  here today I love you so so much  Ariana Grande fights back tears during  her speech at the one love Manchester  benefit concert on Sunday and I would  also say I had the pleasure of meeting  Olivia's mommy a few days ago and as  soon as I met her I started crying I  gave her a big hug and she said that  it's just stop crying cuz Olivia  wouldn't have wanted me to cry and then  she told me that Olivia would have  wanted to hear the hits earlier during  the show ariana performed for the first  time since the may 22nd Manchester  attack that left 22 dead and more than  100 injured proceeds from the concert  will benefit the victims and families  affected by the bombing  [Music]